- Hi, guys.
It's Justine and I'm making a video.
It's weird.
Everything is just so weird right now
and I cannot reiterate enough
whatever you're feeling
right now about everything.
Your feelings are valid
because everyone is
feeling some sort of way
and I don't know how we deal with it
but the one thing that I have realized
is the internet is coming
together as a community,
to really just uplift people,
and I think that's so important right now
and not just on the internet,
in your community is where
you live, neighborhoods,
people are helping each other.
And I've even reached out
to some of my neighbors
and asked if there's
anything that I can do
because I don't know what else to do.
I am actually quarantining myself.
I'm taking those precautions.
The number one thing right now,
is people who don't have symptoms,
they have this and they're
giving it to people
not even knowing that they have it.
So that's why all these
precautions are in place.
I'm not gonna go into it,
but I wanted to just show you guys
some of the tweets that I got today,
because this morning,
I was really having a really
hard time with everything.
I was in my closet, trying
to put laundry away,
and I just started crying
and I want to help.
I don't know what to do.
I think so many of us want to.
And as somebody who does have an audience,
the things that we say,
I hate the term influencer
more than anything,
but in this sense,
that's what we're doing.
I follow a lot of different people.
And the past several weeks,
I'm following these people,
thinking that the things that they say
are things that I can trust,
and it turns out
a lot of people have retweeted
a lot of false information.
And like I said in a previous video,
that's something that I never wanna do.
I never want to be providing
you guys false information.
So I tweeted this this morning,
just asking what can we,
as people who you watch, as influencers,
what can we do?
What do you want from us?
I'd also been talking a bunch
of my other internet friends
who are also making YouTube videos
and we kind of all have the same feeling,
like we wanna do something
but we don't know what to do.
Do we keep making videos?
And that's such an internal conflict
'cause we wanna be sensitive
to what's happening.
And the overwhelming response
that I got to this tweet
was people saying,
"We need you guys more than ever right now
"to keep making the content.
"Don't continually keep
talking about this."
Because that's what the news is doing.
We're being inundated
by so much information.
I think just following
the CDC and websites
that are actually giving
us truthful information
is really the number one thing.
They're telling us to wash our hands,
stay inside because you don't
know if you could have it.
You could be spreading it to someone
who then gives it to their family.
It hurts just to see people
not taking it seriously.
But this thread was so
incredibly refreshing,
which is why I wanted to just
sit here and thank you guys
for your responses
and I wanna read some to you
because if you are somebody
who is making YouTube videos
or making any type of content online,
these were really,
it was really helpful
for me to also read this
and just see what you guys want from us.
So I'm gonna start with Steven
who is also from Pittsburgh
and a gamer and he's
absolutely incredible.
This is what he had to say.
He said, "I honestly believe
"that the best thing that
we can do as influencers,
"no matter, whether you have a hundred
"or a million followers,
"is to keep creating the kind
of content that you want.
"Our obligation is to our community,
"to be the best shepherds we know how.
"That's all anyone can ask of us."
And I think this is really important,
the fact that he's
saying it doesn't matter
if you have a hundred
or a million followers,
even if you just have one or two,
that's some who could
potentially need help,
that's why I'm stressing to you guys,
reach out to your friends.
People that you may not
have talked to in a while.
Ask them if they're okay.
Ask them if their family's okay.
And ask them if anybody needs anything.
'Cause you might have something,
an abundance of maybe some toilet paper
that you could share with
somebody who needs it.
This was a great tweet from James.
So I really appreciate it.
He said to "follow your heart.
"People need information and
they need entertainment."
Even myself.
I have been spending a lot of time,
trying to just find content to watch
and all people are talking about is this.
So I just wanna reiterate,
this is gonna be my last
video about the whole subject.
I mean, I'm gonna be talking about it
but I don't wanna make this
overabundance of content,
just saying the same things
that you guys are hearing on the news
because clearly that's
not what you guys want,
but I just want you to know that
this is a worldwide thing.
We're all going through this.
Not a single person
who feels like they're
the only one doing this.
They're not.
It's really really crazy.
I'm still processing.
I don't even know.
I don't know, I don't know, we don't know.
Rene Ritchie says, "Providing
compassion and escapism.
"Information where we can,
entertainment where needed.
"Helping, never exploiting.
"'Until such time as the world ends,
"'we will act as though
it intends to spin on.'"
Which it does.
And it was really such
a weird thing to see
that Apple had just announced
a bunch of new products
and when you think about it,
they have to.
People still have to have jobs
after all of this is over.
Apple's just a massive company.
So many people work there.
And this isn't just Apple.
All companies have to try to keep going
for the sake of their employees.
For the sake of those people's families.
So, whatever after
this, our new normal is.
That's what it's gonna be.
It's gonna be a new normal
but I'm incredibly confident
that no matter what,
we're gonna figure it out.
People adapt.
And I think that a lot of us
are a lot stronger than we realize,
and I think it's something like this,
that we really can use this
to create a better community,
realize things that are important,
and really just reevaluate
our entire lives
'cause that's definitely
something that I've been doing.
And I think in the end,
it's gonna be a very positive thing.
It might take a while
but I feel like we're all
gonna be so much better
coming out of this and surviving.
Rebecca says, "Being honest."
I think that's incredibly important
because we can't be
spreading misinformation.
"Everyone should do their best
"to spread word of proper
quarantine protocols,
"to be serious about the
situation, without panic,
"stay firm about doing the right thing
"for neighbors, friends,
family, without being negative,
"dispel misinformation,
link good resources."
Definitely, a truth.
I think just linking good
resources is very important.
Just be careful that you are actually
linking something that is legitimate.
"I think influencers
"should be providing
entertainment right now
"of all the things they love the most.
"It'll give people an escape from the news
"and everything that's going on."
"Influencers should keep
making their content.
"We need the distraction.
"Just a little distraction and some videos
"could help us on that end."
Working from home is not an easy thing.
So if any of you guys,
this is something new to you,
that you've never done before,
it is incredibly difficult.
I have been basically working from home
for 13 or 14 years now.
Obviously, in those years I've
been able to sort of set up
a little office space,
and separate my work home life.
But it's still, it's all one.
Everything just mixes together.
So my biggest advice to
somebody who is struggling,
if there's any way,
even if you can just,
mark off a bit of the house
that is a no work zone,
that's gonna be so important,
whether it's your bedroom or the kitchen,
it's like no phones in the
kitchen or no laptops here.
Just setting those small little boundaries
for me has been very helpful,
and I think that
for somebody that's kind
of getting thrown into this
for the first time,
maybe it'll help you, maybe it won't.
I think you guys will
all quickly figure out
what works and what doesn't.
Craig says, "Honestly, carry on as normal.
"I think everyone would be
grateful for a distraction.
"I wanna see your optimism and excitement
"over brightly colored tech.
"Keep doing you."
This also got me thinking,
talking about the new
iPad, and the MacBook,
and all of these new tech things
that are gonna be coming out.
People are gonna have way
less disposable income
to spend on high-priced gadgets.
So reviews are going to be so important
because you don't wanna be
wasting any bit of extra money
on something that you don't
think is gonna be worth it.
And obviously, I think reviews
are very important overall,
but now more than ever,
you don't wanna leave
anything out to chance.
You need to know,
I wanna know.
I don't even wanna be spending extra money
on products to review
that could potentially
not even be worth it.
It probably comes as a surprise
that I do buy a lot of
the tech that I review.
I mean, I'm very lucky
that sometimes companies
will send things.
I would say 70% of the time
I buy a lot of it.
This one, I really like.
"I'm a YouTuber with 300 plus subscribers.
"In my opinion, at this time,
"what we can do is just keep
going as we always have done.
"Also this would be a good time
"to share a skill with your followers.
"Help them develop new skills
"and encourage them to
be creative and busy."
And that's something that
I cannot stress enough.
Just keeping busy.
Working out, I think, is
gonna be very important
for so many people
and it's something that I
definitely struggle with,
because I love group workout classes.
I love going to group yoga classes,
getting into jujitsu in the past two years
has been something that is so,
it's been basically
just a place that I go,
that I can be myself,
not have to worry about anything,
and learn and train,
and now that I haven't
been able to do that,
trying to find ways to keep motivated
and work out at home.
I don't know if you guys have
been paying much attention
to some of the things
that a lot of companies have been doing,
but I've been a huge fan
of Peloton, not sponsored.
They have a really great digital app,
and they're giving people 90 days free
and I am so excited about this
because I love this app so much.
They have so many incredible classes,
their yoga classes are amazing.
So the one upside to a lot of this
is a lot of these companies
are giving away some
incredible things for free.
I usually go to CorePower Yoga.
They have some free online classes.
It's also been so amazing
to see so many jujitsu gyms
giving away their curriculum for free.
Everyone is just kind of banding together
and really just trying
to get through this.
It's also fascinating
because I've had a lot of people
reach out and say,
"What's the best way to
create online content?"
So that's something that
I'm also considering,
is if I can put together a little video
for people who have never
made anything online before.
Here's just a few simple easy steps
and things that you can
do to start creating.
'cause it's a whole 'nother world
and it's just something
that I've really been doing my whole life.
And to throw a company or a small business
into now having to move
everything to digital,
I can't even imagine.
I think it's incredibly difficult.
So I think that's also something
that a lot of us tech people can do,
offer our expertise
and somehow help some of these businesses
through the trying times of
trying to create content online
because it's not easy.
It's not easy at all.
And I think people are
finally realizing that.
So if there's anything you
guys would like to see,
or you think that would be
helpful to people, let me know.
"What I need right is from influencers
"to keep doing what you're doing.
"My life has been interrupted enough,
"no need for changes."
"To put people's mind on something else.
"COVID-19 is everywhere.
"We need some distraction
from this mess and panic.
"We need laughs and we need
to let our brains let go."
I agree, I'm working on it.
I promise, I'm not gonna be
talking much more about this
but I just feel like
this is really important,
just to reiterate to us as creators
that we need to keep creating.
If you, as a person who is
watching content creators,
maybe start creating.
Maybe you'll find yourself
an audience of people
and realize that this
is maybe your passion.
This also, kind of upset me a little bit.
Omar said that, "Girl, I'm in Austin.
"People are having picnics
and playing volleyball.
"Social distancing is not vacation time.
"I don't get it."
I don't get it either
but I also do get it,
because I don't think people realize
that this is very serious.
It just, I mean, the
fact that the whole world
is shutting down, that's not a joke.
I don't know.
I don't understand.
You can go outside.
You can go for walks.
I talked to one of my neighbors today
from across the street, waving.
Don't be going outside and
playing football or a sport,
and sweating all over each other.
That's not a good idea,
and if your friends are asking
you to come play a sport,
say no and that's a bad idea
and please try to encourage them that
that's not a good idea.
Neil is saying, "Supporting mental health
"and people who have kids
at home throughout the day,
"inspiring videos for people of all ages,
"inspiration to create and be productive
"during this unprecedented time."
I can't even image.
Parents trying to entertain
their kids, homeschooling.
There's so many great online
resources for everything.
I don't have children and
I'm not homeschooling.
I probably should be
homeschooling myself in basic math
but if you guys do have any
suggestions on anything,
any websites or anything
that can help other people,
leave them in the comments.
Oh, this is a nice one.
Colby said that they
forgot that I existed.
Okay.
"Modeling good behavior.
"Not to say you need to
lecture people about it,
"just don't model irresponsible behavior.
"Acknowledge that people's
lives are upended,
"but also provide entertainment,
"we still need it.
"In general, that's my thoughts."
There were so many more
and I just really enjoyed reading
all of your guys' responses.
I'm gonna still make videos.
I'm gonna shoot, I'm gonna edit,
and I don't know, this has
always been an outlet for me,
making videos and trying to be creative.
So I look forward to seeing what happens
when we all come out of
this on the other side.
And just I would love to know,
is there a skill or something
that you guys would like to learn
while we're in quarantine?
I think my one skill that
I would like to get out of
however long this is,
is I really wanna be
able to do a handstand.
My sister, Breanne, is
so good at handstands.
She used to be a gymnast,
I do a lot of yoga
but I can never freaking
get the handstand.
I just fall over.
I don't know.
Maybe I have a weak core, whatever it is,
so that's what I'm workin' on over here.
Try to do a handstand.
(chuckling)
(sighing)
Should I try one right here?
I don't know, let me see.
I wanna try.
Oh, I don't like my pants.
I didn't think you guys
would see my pants today.
So one great thing about working at home,
usually nobody ever sees your pants.
Okay, I'm gonna try my handstand.
We're gonna see how it is.
I can't freaking do it.
(loud breathing)
All right, bye.
(beeping)
(coughing)
Oh god.
I'm afraid to even cough now.